eu justice ministers are set to discuss
new rules to better protect personal
information about european citizens at a
meeting in luxembourg on the 7th of
october
the ministers will look notably at the
so-called one-stop shop principle
it would see only one national authority
monitor businesses or organizations to
process personal data in more than one
country ideally that would be the
authority in the state where the
business operates
european efforts to combat
counterfeiting of the euro and other
money is also on the agenda
the ministers hope to agree a common
approach on the definition of criminal
offences and sanctions when it comes to
counterfeit money on october 8 home
affairs ministers will study an interim
report by the european commission on the
free movement of people after a group of
nations expressed concern about possible
abuses
the report looks at whether any rules
were broken and how the problem if there
is one might be avoided in the future
the ministers will also discuss the
protection of refugees who have fled the
conflict in syria according to un
figures more than two million syrians
have taken refuge in neighbouring
countries
in the margins of the talks ministers
will meet with their counterparts from
armenia azerbaijan belarus georgia
moldova and ukraine to discuss
cooperation in the justice and home
affairs sectors it comes ahead of an
eastern partnership summit in vilnius at
the end of november